thank you Yasser we are with Sophie
Maurice Suzuki who won her first game in
this tournament Sophie a difficult start
for you three losses but finally after
the rest day you came re-energized and
won a brilliant game how do you feel
right now
finally finally I have a game in this
tournament that I can look back on and
say hey I actually played good chess
you did indeed uh take us through the
game actually did you prepare a lot
yesterday how did you spend your rest
day
um I spent it trying to motivate myself
to prepare and failing for the most part
um I think I just ate too much food as I
always do and
I don't know like I I did I did
eventually get myself to do a little
prep
um which didn't actually happen on the
board in this game so I was mostly just
winging it for the opening phase of this
game were you prepping a lot at the
beginning at the onset of this
tournament and things were not working
well and you felt like you need to
change something
um well none of my opponents were going
into my prep so I don't know I kind of
just got less and less motivated
especially since I wasn't winning games
so
but you definitely took down Rochelle in
this one take us through the critical
moments of this one
she was super aggressive with this move
G4
yeah I know that G4 is an idea but I'm
not sure if I I knew it was an idea with
some Bishop D6 line I wasn't sure if it
was an idea here but it seemed it seems
to be
um it seems to be a thing according to
the database because there are games not
many but there are some some high level
games cards and carwanov iruga versus
Wesley so it has been played before
how did you assess this one and how
would you uh come up with your idea in
the game
uh well I was kind of just like
my opponent was making
um was was playing really aggressively
and like
trying to make stuff happen so I could
also make stuff happen
um
Bishop B4 the idea of this move is
to me G5 with Knight E4
um like I I could
now this now 94 is really effective here
so I thought Bishop B4 was a better move
than like I don't know Bishop D6 or
something makes a lot of sense yeah she
played Bishop D3 C5 take on C5 Knight C6
sacrificed the pawn and uh now you took
the pawn back
but you have the bishoper and she
castled then yesterday at this point was
asking who is Rochelle's coach because
you cannot short Castle in play the move
G4 you cannot combine those ideas were
you
um as confused as we were as well
more or less I don't know I mean it's
also like what does white do because
castling queenside is technically
possible but also doesn't look very good
and what other moves does white make
because
I don't even know like your g-pawn is
you're not really in a position to pawn
storm me
um so
yeah I'm not really sure what else white
could do castling either way seems like
the only options to develop both the
Rooks but like foreign
doesn't seem like he's going anywhere
and tell us where do you feel like
you're pretty much have this one in the
back
you got the pawn
you got into this very very favorable uh
end game
it felt like you're on your way to
winning it did you feel like you let any
of your advantage go at any point or was
just smooth sailing or all throughout I
was pretty happy with my position like
all throughout I don't know if I could
have done something better I
I have a feeling that like when I look
at this game afterwards it's gonna it's
gonna say something like the engine's
probably gonna say that like I had a
better option I you know my technique
was not the best but
it was good enough so yeah Sophie
congratulations a big first victory for
you still several rounds to turn this
event around we'll be seeing you in the
remainder of your games
thank you oh congratulations as well
Sophie uh definitely nice to get